there are two things you need to know
about this sample first how to hook it
up to the translation web surface and
second how to write the code to call the
service so let's take a look first to
run the sample yourself you'll need to
sign up for a developer account on
Windows Azure and get an app ID use the
app ID to configure your version of the
sample right here in translation service
that's es the developer account allows
you to develop and debug your app for
free only when you roll your app out
commercially is there a charge for the
service next understand that the sample
app runs is a Silverlight contextual
data application so you need to register
the application on each client that runs
the application see here's the registry
entry on my computer to find out more
about contextual data in the registry
entry see MSDN docs here in my case to
make it easy for me i registered my apps
as default applications so whenever an
iamb is received on that computer the
conversation window extension opens up
containing the translation application
like this you need to install and
register the app on each client where
you want to deploy the service so onto
the code if the translator app is
running when an instant message is
received this event fires you can see
from the comments that the event gets
the contacts name gets the message text
and then calls another event here see
here that in this event the author
creates a context object of type message
context the context object properties
are set the code verifies there were
only two participants and then calls the
translate method on the translation
service object here in this method the
app checks the language of the incoming
message if needed and then calls the do
translate method here where the app
calls the azure translation service you
can see the parameters include your
Azure appid
message text
source and target languages a callback
method and the context object that we
talked about earlier and the callback
right here passes the translated message
back to the application UI for display